nous sommes avec françois morton à
présent bonjour à vous bonjour mr de
guyancourt nous allons voir comment
votre ville gère cette période de
confinement quels sont les services déjà
les services municipaux qui fonctionne
aujourd'hui et depuis le 17 mars
alors depuis le début du confinement en
fait nous avons fait le choix de
conserver une permanence un accueil
physique tous les matins de 9h à 11h
pour les situations d'urgence et bien
évidemment l'ensemble des habitants peut
continuer à contacter les services de la
ville au numéro du standard verture
habituelles de la vie mais on a plutôt
en ce sens un service d'astreinte a
effectivement on adaptera les personnels
doivent intervenir en fonction des
problématiques rencontrées
on note aussi qu' en élan de solidarité
partout qui s'est manifesté c'est le cas
aussi pour l'aiguillon courtoise élégant
courtois ya une plate forme que vous
avez lancé pour recenser un petit peu
tout ça alors cette pâle cette
plateforme s appelle le soyons
solidaires alors elle est assez simple
d'utilisation en fait hein c'est à dire
que elle met en lien les besoins les
réponses à ces besoins
vous pouvez avoir un certain nombre
besoin de besoins du type je ne peux pas
un crime et une attestation de sortie
par exemple ou alors j'ai des
difficultés à les faire mes courses et
de l'autre côté vous avez des habitants
qui se proposent pour effectivement
répondre à ses besoins et donc cette
plateforme mais tout simplement les gens
en contact
on peut voir aussi que donc la
solidarité s'exprime et vient votre site
internet vous avez décidé chaque jour de
relayer aussi des personnalités un petit
peu qui se démarquent
oui c'est vrai que c'est important aussi
de mettre du positif période un petit
peu morose j'ai envie de dire et donc
c'est important de pouvoir mettre en
lumière un certain nombre d'acteurs et
on va poursuivre ce système parce que
c'est vraiment important alors sur la
page facebook aussi on met du positif ce
qui est important c'est par exemple
comment rendre cette morosité au travers
vous les connaissez aussi à toutes ces
vidéos humoristiques ou alors comment
faire du sport ou comment effectivement
faire de la danse enfin des choses comme
ça que vous pouvez retrouver tout à fait
facilement soit sur le site de la ville
souhaite sur la page fais ça c'est pour
tout l'aspect positif est qu'il faut
relayer sur l'aspect aussi des des
contraintes il ya un confinement à faire
respecter la police municipale y veille
comment l'eau services municipaux
travail est ce que ce confinement
aussi est globalement respecté on l'a
entendu il ya toujours des rappels un
petit peu qu'il faut faire de temps en
temps alors la très grande majorité je
le dis très clairement la très grande
majorité des gluants courtois respecte
parfaitement ce confinement et on n'est
pas à l'abri de rencontrer une toute
petite minorité de personnes soit qui
n'ont pas forcément bien conquis les
consignes au démarrage et il était
important de les rappeler au travers de
nos canaux de communication bien
évidemment ou qui ne souhaite pas
certain nombre de fois respectée c'est
cette période de confinement et la
police municipale ou toujours en
articulation avec la police nationale
parce que telle est notre projet depuis
toujours admis en cours c'est cette
articulation avec la police nationale et
est amené bien évidemment à verbaliser
et la police municipale est en
permanence dans les rues de la petite
après six semaines les choses se sont
mis en place non il faut penser aux
déconfinement aussi en tout cas au début
de déconfinement qui devrait intervenir
autour du du 11 mai aujourd'hui vous
avez des discussions avec les services
de l'état aujourd'hui vous réfléchissez
sur la réouverture des écoles qui les
écoles la gestion des écoles qui fait
partie des prérogatives des meilleurs
justement alors d'une manière plus
globale depuis le début du confinement
j'ai envie de dire on va pas qu'on fout
complètement des continents depuis début
du confinement je le précise
on a toujours été en relation avec nos
acteurs institutionnels traditionnels
que ce soit le préfet la région
ile-de-france de département
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines bien évidemment et c'est grâce
d'ailleurs à ce partenariat qui
fonctionne plutôt bien que nous avons pu
nous procurer un certain nombre de
matériels
je pense notamment aux masques
chirurgicaux par exemple ont été
distribués aux professionnels de santé
le gel hydroalcoolique nous avons puisé
dans nos propres commandes réserve pour
toujours privilégier ces professionnels
de santé et puis effectivement nous
sommes en discussion alors
il est temps maintenant de passer à une
nouvelle phase vous l'avez dit c'est
celle de l'anticipation du déconfinement
je pense qu'il faut arrêter de subir les
déclarations les unes après les autres
et de s'adapter au fur et à mesure mais
de commencer un travail de son
d'anticipation de ceux des confinement
donc on suit de près et effectivement ce
que peut dire le président de la
république le premier ministre bien
entendu je suis parfois en décalé le
ministre de l'éducation nationale mais
c'est une autre problème est
effectivement on est sur cette
anticipation du déconfinement mais vous
voyez bien que la réouverture des écoles
par exemple entraîne en cascade un
certain nombre de réouverture de service
quid du périscolaire par exemple des
accueils de loisirs quand ce n'est
accueils du matin les accueils du soir
tout cela sera géré par les mairies
après là vous vous êtes en train de voir
comment vous organisez pour ça alors on
est obligé de commencer à y réfléchir
voilà c'est j'ai envie de te dire comme
ça et c'est pour ça que nous avons un
certain nombre de réunions de travail
avec les directeurs de la ville en
charge de tous ces secteurs on voit
comment le moment venu on va pouvoir
mettre en pratique effectivement ces
diverses ouvertures
sachant que nous ne sommes pas naïfs et
que comme l'a dit d'ailleurs le premier
ministre tout ne va pas rouvrir du jour
au lendemain bien évidemment les
cantines pourrait ouvrir par exemple ce
serait ce sera faisable ça serait cool
sur quoi sur une base de volontariat
aussi peut-être du personnel alors
depuis le début du décompte du
confinement pardon nous accueillons déjà
un certain nombre d'enfants qui sont les
enfants des professionnels de santé de
sécurité
nous avons été une des premières
communes à tout de suite accueillir
d'ailleurs les enfants des
professionnels des métiers de la
sécurité car il était important de
pouvoir les prendre en charge et donc
dans ce cadre la demi pension est déjà
assurée lors qu'elle est évidemment s'il
ya une reprise de l'école il faut de
toute façon songer à une reprise des
temps de demi pension et des temps j'ai
envie de dire quel scolaire d'une
manière plus globale il ya la question
des masques aussi comment se passe la
gestion des masses qu'est ce que vous
faites des stocks vous allez en
distribuant ici vraiment la réponse est
oui c'est à dire qu'il est hors de
question d'attendre effectivement une
dotation
potentiel qui pourrait arriver de l'état
c'est à dire que nous devons être
responsables et nous avons déjà en ce
sens passé des commandes pour des
masques chirurgicaux mais également par
des masques tissu lavable et
réutilisable
il y aura des distributions à la
population aussi dans certaines communes
ce sera le cas est ce que ce sera le cas
à guyancourt
ce sera le cas guyancourt bien
évidemment j'ai envie de dire que pour
l'instant je suis dans l'incapacité je
dis très clairement d'annoncer des
délais je souhaite que toutes ces
masques alors les masques chirurgicaux
g je suis plutôt confiant sur cette
arrivée avant le 11 mai sur les masques
d'issue je pense qu'on sera à peu près
dans la période
merci beaucoup françois morton maire de
guyancourt d'avoir été en ligne avec
nous pour faire ce point sur la
situation actuellement et puis sur cette
réflexion qui est plus que s'engage
aujourd'hui sur le déconfinement merci à
vous merci rond